WE'RE NOT ADHERING TO EVERY
OSCAR TRADITION TONIGHT.
BUT I AM SO HAPPY THAT I NOW
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT THE
AWARD FOR BEST SUPPORTING ACTOR.
EACH OF THESE FIVE ARTISTS
CONTRIBUTED TO THE LARGER
CULTURAL CONVERSATION THROUGH
THEIR STORYTELLING THIS YEAR.
PRESENTING US WITH THEMES OF
EQUITY AND SOCIAL JUSTICE IN
THEIR OWN UNIQUE AND
EXTRAORDINARY WAYS.
LAKEITH STANFIELD.
"JUDAS AND THE BLACK MESSIAH."
LAKEITH, WITH SUCH POWER,
YOU GAVE US AN EXPERIENCE OF WHAT IT
IS WHEN CITIZENS ARE BETRAYED BY
THEIR OWN COUNTRY AND WHILE
GRAPPLING WITH MORALITY,
THEY MUST FIGHT TO SURVIVE.
DANIEL KALUUYA,
"JUDAS AND THE BLACK MESSIAH."
DANIEL, HI.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, THANK YOU
BECAUSE WITH YOUR EXTRAORDINARY
COMMITMENT AND YOUR ENDLESS
RESEARCH, YOU DID IN FACT
BEAUTIFULLY GET WITHIN THE MAN
AND I HAVE BEEN LISTENING TO YOU
SPEAK OF YOUR INSPIRATION IN
DENZEL WASHINGTON'S PERFORMANCE
IN "MALCOLM X."
AND JUST TO SAY HOW GRATEFUL WE
ARE FOR THE INSPIRATION YOU GAVE
US, WITH NOT ONLY THE ROLE, BUT
THE WORDS YOU SHARED, AND THE
REMINDER THAT YOU CAN'T MURDER
FREEDOM.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
TO LESLIE ODOM JR.,
"ONE NIGHT IN MIAMI."
[ APPLAUSE ]
LESLIE, THE GORGEOUS WEIGHT OF
RESPONSIBILITY THAT YOU CARRIED
IN THESE DISCUSSIONS IN AND
AROUND ADVANCING SOCIAL JUSTICE.
IT CAPTURED OUR HEARTS FOREVER,
AS DID YOUR CHILLING GIFT OF
BRINGING SAM COOKE BACK TO US.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
TO PAUL RACI, "SOUND OF METAL."
PAUL, GROWING UP AS A HEARING PERSON
WITH DEAF PARENTS, I KNOW YOU
MADE SUCH A TIRELESS COMMITMENT
TO EXPAND THE NARROWED
PERSPECTIVE OF DEAF CHARACTERS
IN FILM.
WITH THIS BRILLIANT PERFORMANCE,
YOU GAVE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TRULY UNDERSTAND WHAT
INCLUSIVITY MEANS.
AND WE'RE SO LUCKY.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND TO SACHA BARON COHEN, "THE
TRIAL OF THE CHICAGO 7."
WITH YOUR PERFECT PORTRAYAL OF
THE YIPPIE ICONOCLAST
ABBIE HOFFMAN, YOU LEANED INTO
YOUR ACTIVIST INSTINCTS.
AND I'M STUNNED YOU WOULD BE
ATTRACTED TO PLAYING SUCH A
DISRUPTOR, IT'S SO UNLIKE YOU TO
ROCK THE BOAT.
BUT THAT'S WHY THEY CALL IT
ABOUTING.
THESE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR BEST
ACTOR IN A SUPPORTING ROLE.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
DANIEL KALUUYA,
"JUDAS AND THE BLACK MESSIAH."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪
ALL RIGHT.
MAN.
THANK YOU, GOD.
I CAN'T BE HERE WITHOUT YOUR
GUIDANCE AND PROTECTION.
FOR MY MOM, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR POURING INTO ME, YOU GAVE ME
EVERYTHING.
YOU GAVE ME YOUR FACTORY
SETTINGS.
SO I CAN STAND AT MY FULLEST
HEIGHT.
LOVE TO MY SISTER, MY NIECE, MY
FRIENDS AND FAMILY, EVERYONE I
LOVE, FROM LONDON TOWN TO KAMPALA.
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY TEAM.
INCREDIBLE SUPPORT.
BRO, WE OUT HERE.
YO.
MAN.
IT'S GOOD, COME ON DOWN.
RYAN, ZINZI, SEV, EVERYONE AT
PROXMITY
CHARLES KING.
EVERYONE AT MACRO.
BRON. PARTICIPANT.
NIGEL, EVERYONE AT WARNER
BROTHERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
EVERYTHING YOU POURED INTO THIS.
IT'S SO HARD TO MAKE A FILM
ABOUT A MAN LIKE THIS,
AND THEY MADE THIS POSSIBLE.
THEY MADE IT HAPPEN.
I SHARE THIS HONOR WITH THE GIFT
THAT IS LAKEITH STANFIELD.
THE LIGHT THAT IS -- YEAH.
YEAH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE LIGHT THAT IS DOMINIQUE
FISHBACK.
THE INCREDIBLE CAST AND CREW.
LUCAS BROTHERS, FOR
STARTING THE JOURNEY
WILL BERSON. SEE IT'S SO INCREDIBLE TO LOOK
AROUND YOU, TO LOOK AROUND YOU
AND JUST GO, YOU'RE INSPIRED BY
NOT ONLY WHAT THEY DO, BUT WHO
THEY ARE.
THAT'S AMAZING.
CHAIRMAN FRED JUNIOR AND MAMA AKUA
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
US INTO YOUR LIFE AND INTO YOUR
STORY.
THANK YOU FOR TRUSTING US, YOU
KNOW, WITH YOUR TRUTH.
I APPRECIATE YOU DEEPLY.
IT'S AN HONOR TO PARTNER UP AND
STAND SIDE-BY-SIDE WITH YOU.
AND TO CHAIRMAN FRED HAMPTON,
BRO, MAN, MAN.
WHAT A MAN.
HOW BLESSED WE ARE THAT WE LIVE
IN A LIFETIME WHERE HE EXISTED.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LIGHT.
HE WAS ON THIS EARTH
FOR 21 YEARS
AND HE FOUND A WAY TO FEED KIDS
BREAKFAST.
EDUCATE KIDS, GIVE FREE MEDICAL CARE.
AGAINST ALL THE ODDS, HE SHOWED
ME, HE TAUGHT ME, HIM, HUEY P.
NEWTON,  BOBBY SEALE
THE BLACK PANTHER PARTY, THEY
SHOWED ME OUT TO LOVE MYSELF,
AND WITH THAT LOVE, THEY
OVERFLOWED INTO THE BLACK COMMUNITY
AND OTHER COMMUNITIES.
AND THEY SHOWED US THE  POWER
OF UNION, THE POWER OF UNITY
WHEN THEY PLAY DIVIDE AND CONQUER,
WE SAY UNITE AND ASCEND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SHOWING ME MYSELF.
AND THERE'S SO MUCH
WORK TO DO, GUYS.
THAT'S ON EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM.
THIS AIN'T NO SINGLE MAN JOB.
I LOOK AT EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF YOU.
WE'VE GOT WORK TO DO.
AND I'M GOING TO GET BACK TO
WORK TUESDAY MORNING.
BECAUSE TONIGHT I'M GOING UP.
WE'RE GOING UP, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN?
WE'RE ENJOYING OURSELVES
TONIGHT.
YOU GOT TO CELEBRATE LIFE, MAN.
WE'RE BREATHING, WALKING,
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
MY MOM, MY DAD, THEY HAD SEX.
IT'S AMAZING.
YOU UNDERSTAND, I'M HERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I'M SO HAPPY TO BE ALIVE.
SO I'M GOING TO CELEBRATE TONIGHT.
I APPRECIATE EVERYONE IN THE
ROOM, EVERYONE WATCHING AT HOME.
YOU KNOW, PEACE, LOVE, AND
ONWARDS.
WE GO AGAIN.